[Music]  oh god sorry frank  sorry strong form  my name is dr lily houghton my brother  and i are looking for passage upriver  what's out there in the jungle it's not  a fun vacation well i'm not here for a  vacation  legend has it that there is a tree that  possesses unparalleled healing power it  will change medicine  forever and you need someone to help you  find it here we go  sometimes it just needs a bit of a  nobody touches my engine but me  what did i just there you go  we're gonna do this together haven't you  been dreaming about adventure  she was always chasing after some  far-fetched idea  [Applause]  [Music]  do you want to turn back nope just  getting started  [Music]  oh my gosh  a lotion  [Music]  you